nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
it's been another week and it's time for
a
covid weekly update tuesday seem to be a
good day for these because it allows
sort of the weekend data to be smoothed
out sometimes on the weekends there's
these
dumps of data sometimes on the weekends
data and reporting slow down
on vaccines or cases or whatever so
looking at it tuesday wednesday
seems to make sense and we're going to
look again at cases to begin with but
increasingly
you know as more and more people get
vaccinated uh
and getting the virus for the vaccinated
means something much less serious than
it used to for unvaccinated people cases
may
become less an important indicator than
hospitalizations
and of course deaths as our more
important measures but let's start
where we always do with cases cases in
the united states
peaked on january 11th at the incredible
and nearly unbelievable number of 255
000 cases per day
since that peak cases have declined
about 78 percent
to 55 000 cases per day now 55 000 cases
per day is still outrageous and when we
got
up to 55 000 cases per day we were
completely horrified and rightly so
many never imagined we'd ever get to 55
000 cases a day remember some people
told us
15 cases will soon be zero but right now
55 000 cases a day means we're down 78
in about two months so that's the right
direction if we
saw another 78 percent decline over the
next two months
we'd be at about 12 000 cases in mid-may
now it's unclear whether that's going to
happen the decline has already slowed
down
but at the same time if vaccination
continues to accelerate
maybe the decline will accelerate as
well we just don't know right now
in terms of people going into the
hospital each day
with the virus we peaked right around
january 9th
when 16 000 people were being
hospitalized
each day with the virus in the united
states
we are now at 4 500 people being
hospitalized
each day with the virus that's a decline
of 73
and then in terms of the total number of
people in the hospital with kovid right
now
that peak was also on january 10th when
we had 124
000 people in the hospital that number
is down
75 percent to 30 000 people
remaining in the hospital with covid in
the united states and then
deaths deaths peaked around the end of
january
at more than a 9 11's worth of deaths
every day we were seeing about 3 400
deaths a day
at the end of january deaths are now
down
to an average of 1282
which is still horrifying but it's a
decline of 63
it's tough to be happy about 1282 people
dying a day of this
virus and yet we recognize that being
down 63
to 1282 is better than a continued spike
to 1282 in the sense that the direction
we're going in is the right one
and remember that death's trail cases by
a few weeks
they're a lagging indicator so we expect
that deaths would continue down
similar to cases but again at a certain
point
as more people get vaccinated and people
start doing more things
you may see cases level out because
people will be transmitting the virus
but because so many people will be
vaccinated they're not going to be
seriously ill
that may happen we're not there yet but
we may be going in that direction now
lastly vaccination
vaccination we want to see going up of
most of these indicators indicators we
want to see go down
vaccinations you want to see go up and
we are now averaging 2.4 million vaccine
doses injected per day
over the last week that is a number that
continues to go up
last week we were at 2.1 million a day
now we're at 2.4
million a day and we have roughly 38
million
fully vaccinated americans and another
32 million
partially vaccinated that means about 70
million americans are fully or partially
vaccinated
these are increasingly good numbers to
see
now one last thing these are all u.s
numbers
what is happening globally with the
virus is the virus
growing or diminishing globally and the
answer is it sort of depends
there are parts of the world seeing
spikes look at brazil
brazil has been one of the worst places
in the world for covet handling thanks
to
bolsonaro it actually is now peaking
brazil is now at the highest of its
four or five peaks with more active
cases today
than at any point during the pandemic in
brazil there are some european countries
starting to spike vaccine rollout has
not been great in many parts of europe
and indeed globally overall
cases are going up while they are down
almost 80 percent in the u.s
cases are going up globally cases
globally bottomed out
at around 360 000 a day uh
not long ago a few weeks ago they are
now back up to 430
000 global cases a day fortunately
deaths continue to decline partially
because
many countries are getting better at
treating people who get seriously ill
partially because the world is starting
to vaccinate uh the most
at-risk individuals but deaths peaked
around
14 000 a day in early february there are
now 8 500 people a day
globally dying of coronavirus so the
takeaways are there's a ton of work to
be done
numbers are improving in countries that
have done more vaccination
but there are still parts of the world
seeing more cases there are still parts
of the world
that aren't likely to get any
significant number of vaccines for a
long time
all we can do is go by the guidelines
that our
respective health authorities are giving
us in the us it's the cdc
cdc urging caution but opening up
some safe activities for vaccinated
people we will give it another week
and then see where things are there's a
new report that the biden administration
is planning what is being called the
biggest tax increase in 30 years now i
want to be really careful in how i
report this because first of all
tax increase is a relative term in that
much of what joe biden wants to do
would be to undo in some cases
only some of the republican tax
decreases
of the past decades also none of what is
being reported
is outside of what joe biden promised to
do
so we're seeing all of these hot takes
about shocking betrayal by biden of
i don't know what because he told us
when he ran
what his tax plan was going to be and
the reports
from bloomberg yesterday which broke
this story
that joe biden's next big uh project
is tax reform it's the stuff he told us
he was going to do so let's look at it
the reported biden tax plan priorities
are to increase the income tax rate on
people making more than four hundred
thousand dollars a year remember that's
earned income separate from capital
gains which we will get to
joe biden would expand the estate tax
which
we don't have the details yet you could
expand the estate tax in two ways
you could make it kick in at a lower
level of wealth
or you could increase the rate at which
uh estates are taxed
joe biden will re this is the report
from bloomberg says
joe biden will look to reduce tax
preferences on pass
through businesses which would affect
the david pakman show uh would increase
uh uh to a higher capital gains tax rate
for people making over one million
dollars per year
would increase the corporate tax rate
from 21 to 28 percent
and in all likelihood even if he were to
move on this
very soon nothing would take effect
until at least 2022
as a tax year meaning that you would
deal with these
changes sometime between january
and april 15th of 2023 that that's right
now and of course that may change now
let's just pick one of these because so
much of this is being is being sort of
misunderstood
the corporate tax rate what joe biden
wants to do is increase it from 21 to 28
according to this report it's important
to remember
that the corporate tax rate number one
used to be in the mid-40s
and then it dropped to the low 40s then
35 percent and it stood at 35 for a very
long time
then it went to 21 under trump so what
joe biden would do
would be to only go partially back
to the long-standing corporate tax rate
of 35
by going to 28. it's not exactly radical
and then
just as importantly there's so many
people saying
going to 28 will hurt small businesses
this is a fun
fundamental misunderstanding of most
small businesses most small businesses
if you're a sole proprietor if you are
an llc
or an s corporation this doesn't affect
you
because all of those business entities
are taxed at the personal rate what i
mean by that is
if you have a personal house cleaning
business
and you make sixty thousand dollars you
don't pay
a 21 or 28 or 35 corporate tax rate
you were taxed on that 60 000 on the
personal
income tax rates now my prediction is
that politically a lot of this stuff is
going to be really tough right now
because of the pandemic and we'll talk
to bill share about this a little bit
later on on the program
of course republicans are all going to
say we should never do tax increases but
in particular we shouldn't do them right
now
because of the pandemic there are also
going to be some democrats who will make
that case particularly
in the senate i do think that increasing
the corporate tax rate
is the easiest thing to do that joe
biden is proposing
i believe that the other aspects of this
are going to see significant political
difficulty i'm not saying it shouldn't
happen
i am merely giving you my opinion of
what i predict is going to happen
now i i we talked about some of the
changes that are going to be made there
um in in terms of pass-through
uh entities and different things the the
tax plan joe biden is proposing if it
happens
is going to lead to me as the owner of
the david pakman show
paying more in taxes and i'm okay with
that
as long as the money is being put to
good use
which it already is not and as i've said
before many times
we could and should be rethinking our
spending priorities now
and we may not even have to increase
taxes to fund the programs that are
important to us
that's separate from whether
billionaires and millionaires should be
paying more
uh and and and they should um but uh
of the roughly 1.5 trillion dollars in
discretionary spending
that the federal government does almost
half of it is for the military
what that's insane so i'm not saying
have no military i'm not saying be weak
i'm not saying anything other than half
of our discretionary spending
shouldn't be going to the military and
that's a conversation that is a
conversation that must be had regardless
of what the tax rate is on whoever
now the question here is less an
economic one than a political one
we know that joe biden's plan would be
deficit negative it would raise more
money than it would cost
that we that's been analyzed by the tax
policy center we know that
uh the question is going to be my
instinct
is that you are going to see republicans
and some democrats come together and say
it's not the right time to do this
let's see how it goes for now the white
house is simply saying
without commenting on the bloomberg
report anything we do
would not increase the taxes of people
making under four hundred thousand
dollars
per year that's the statement from the
white house so far
friday march 26th one day membership
special
massive blowout huge dumps of discounted
memberships are going to be coming in
to be notified about how to take
advantage of the march
26th special simply get on my newsletter
by signing up at davidpakman.com we'll
take a quick break and if you're on
twitter let me know
do you think joe biden can get tax
reform done this year
in the current political climate find me
on twitter at dpakman let me know what
you think
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
off all nebia products this really has
to be seen to be believed and i believe
you will believe it momentarily i told
you yesterday how republicans and donald
trump are now
a very aggressively demanding credit for
the coronavirus vaccines
which they said we didn't really need to
end the pandemic
and that the pandemic wasn't really
serious anyway
and which many of them are refusing to
take that vaccine
is the one they now want credit for well
there's now
layer two of this which is that there
are now
many republican lawmakers who voted
against the recent 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted stimulus bill that was recently
passed by
democrats exclusively and democrats
alone who want to take credit for it
republicans who want to take credit for
it let's look at some examples here is
republican congresswoman
maria salazar tweeting over the weekend
quote
so proud to announce that the biden
administration
has just implemented my bipartisan covid
relief
bill as part of small business poli
small business administration policy
she voted against it she didn't vote for
it
and now she wants credit for it and
there are
so many of these republican senator from
mississippi
roger wicker did the exact same thing
tweeting how glad he is that quote
independent restaurant operators have
won 28 billion dollars
worth of targeted relief he's cheering
that quote this funding will ensure
small
businesses can survive the pandemic
by helping to adapt their operations
and keep their employees on the payroll
but he voted against the bill
and now he wants credit for it and he's
bragging about it and apparently he's
going to campaign on this
republican congressman adam kinzinger
tweeted that quote we owe it to the
american people
to work together in doing everything we
can
to get them the coveted relief they need
bipartisanship
is critical ineffective legislating
except he voted against it
and there was no bipartisanship despite
significant republican support
for the coveted relief bill and then in
a statement that adam kinzinger
links to he actually says today
i'm glad to know my constituents will be
receiving an additional relief payment
and funding to help improve their access
to vaccines ppe
and unemployment insurance but he voted
against it and in the statement he adds
but the legislation passed today
is one of the largest expenditures in
american history
with spending unrelated to the coveted
19 pandemic and republicans were left
out of all negotiations now
it's untrue that republicans were left
out of all negotiations we've already
talked about this bullet point that's
floating around saying
91 of the money wasn't for covid
wasn't actually coveted relief well that
depends on how you define it
and much of it is for infrastructure uh
affected by
coronavirus public transit affected by
coronavirus when people aren't riding
public transit
corona public transit infrastructure
deteriorates
and then we come out of the pandemic
with even
even crappier for lack of a better term
public transit infrastructure which
the u.s already doesn't do particularly
well in so
we did all this debunking already
but still he wants credit even though he
voted against it
radical extremist q anon congresswoman
lauren bobert defiantly tweeting that
hell yes you should be getting the money
why it's your money after all that you
already paid into the government in
taxes
saying quote the framing of stimulus
checks
is all wrong this is not fourteen
hundred dollars being given to you by
your generous government
this is money that you and your fellow
countrymen already paid into the system
so
if she thinks it's taxpayer money that
should go back to taxpayers
why did she vote against the money going
back to taxpayers
how can republicans who voted against
the bill
take credit for the bill and sadly part
of the answer is
if their own constituents are ignorant
enough to fall for it
and it appears that many are i mean
after all they're the same people that
voted for donald trump
if they're if they're dumb enough to
fall for it why not go with it and thus
these republicans are setting themselves
up to when it's convenient
say i refused the pork
of the coveted stimulus but talking out
of the other side of their mouths
they can also say i am so glad
that the congress i was a part of
delivered money to my constituents
they're gonna try to play both sides
and um in a way it's kind of simpler for
us
that they all voted against it and what
i mean by that is like if some
republicans had voted for the coveted
relief bill
we would have to say okay let's see rand
paul is trying to take credit for the
bill
we have to check did rand vote for it or
did rand vote against it
they all voted against it every single
one of them so
if they have an r next to their name
between now and 2022
you know they voted against the bill and
we can save ourselves the time of having
to actually look it up
so we have a new talking point
about coronavirus vaccines that is
getting
oxygen and the talking point is these
are not vaccines they are and then you
can kind of choose your own adventure
they aren't vaccines
they are dna modifiers they aren't
vaccines
they are gene therapies genetic
therapies
and there's a few other versions of it
and it's actually been around for some
time
but it's now catching on more and more
let's listen to
former trump advisor and breitbart
propagandist
stephen bannon making this claim
on his show some kind of show that he
has let's take a listen to this
actual conversation and debate these are
not
technically vaccines right the first
ones are
they're experimental gene therapies
every scientist i've talked to admits
that
and and here why can't you even i'm not
an anti-vaxxer
i we're the ones and look at this show
is specialized in whether you think it's
a bio weapon
from the wuhan lab that either let out
on purpose or interven
inadvertently escaped or if you think
it's a total hoax
so steve bannon there also actually gets
into the entire
the virus is a bio weapon stuff
but you know we can't do everything in
one clip let's focus on what he said
about
vaccines because it's more relevant
whether or not you believe the virus is
a bio weapon
i don't think that impacts your interest
in a vaccine if you believe that the
vaccines aren't really vaccines that
might actually
impact whether you want a vaccine so
let's focus on that steve bannon says
these are not technically vaccines they
are
experimental gene therapies
and this has been floating around and
the kernel of this
where does this come from the kernel is
that
with a so-called normal vaccine
or so-called real vaccine the body
is developing immunity on the basis of a
deactivated or weakened virus
that is in the vaccine and that is what
generates the immune response now these
mrna vaccines messenger rna vaccines
they don't contain deactivated virus
but they contain sequenced
virus and instructions that
they say quote modify your dna that's
the talking point
it's a dna modification but let's go
piece by piece
first of all steve says it's
experimental what does he mean by that i
don't know
mrna vaccine research has been going on
for decades
they've been studied for flu zika
rabies and cmv vaccination so
experimental
not really it's been it's been studied
for decades second
and this is probably the key part the
mrna vaccine
contains instructions for your body to
make
the spike protein that the coronavirus
has
so the idea is your body makes all these
spike proteins
if you get the live virus in you the
body recognizes that protein because the
mrna vaccine
already told the body how to make it it
doesn't make you sick because it quickly
quickly dispatches with the real virus
okay where they get it's not a vaccine
is that it is not a weakened or
deactivated virus
that is triggering your body to make the
spike protein it is messenger rna
mrna triggering your body to make the
spike protein that doesn't mean it's not
a vaccine
it's merely a different method of
achieving the same thing
so it's not experimental it is a vaccine
it's not a gene therapy and it doesn't
alter your dna
everything steve bannon says is untrue
now let's continue
to another piece of the clip which is
equally lie riddled take a look at this
they're going to get to a part a point
very quickly if you don't have the
vaccine you're not going to get the
vaccine passport
and if in other words you're not going
to be able to get on a plane you're not
gonna be able to get on public
transportation
basically you're not gonna be able to
hold a job okay and yet they don't want
any debate whatsoever not from people
that are anti-vaxxers the people just
have legitimate hey can you walk me
through this again
what phase of this is really in testing
it's got emergency
authorized use by the fda so now he goes
into it will be mandatory vaccination
as evidenced by an airline might say if
you want to fly with us you need a
vaccine certificate
or live nation or ticketmaster or
whoever might say if you want to come to
a concert at one of our venues for which
we sell tickets
you need a vaccine certificate first of
all that's not the government making
anything
mandatory and it's not the government
doing anything at all those are private
companies
second is steve bannon saying that the
government gets to tell private
companies
you can't require proof of vaccination
is that
i mean the these are small government
free market conservatives
who seem to want it to be made illegal
by the government
for a private company to say we
if you want to avail yourself of our
product or service
we require you to show proof of
vaccination if requiring vaccination
is bad for like imagine delta or jetblue
says
you know after september 1 after january
1 you need to be vaccinated to fly with
us which they haven't done by the way
maybe they would
if they do that and it's a bad business
idea the market will punish them
because all of the unvaccinated people
who want to fly
will switch from delta or jetblue to
some airline that doesn't require a
vaccine
that's the market well what if every
airline requires a vaccine
then the free market has created an
opportunity for a
new airline to come in and take all the
customers
that want to fly without being
vaccinated that's how right wingers
sell us on the magic and efficiency
and perfection of free markets and yet
now
they're using yes conspiracy theories
that aren't going to become a thing
to i guess argue for the exact opposite
which would be very heavy-handed
regulation by a government
they tend to claim shouldn't be involved
in regulating private industry unless
absolutely and completely necessary
these people are not just pathetic
but they're spreading dangerous
conspiracy theories
that reduce the number of people who
might want the vaccine
and it's getting it's like whack-a-mole
it's getting harder and harder in fact i
even have
i i even as a as a a visual aid i even
have my uh
my gavel it is like playing whack-a-mole
here trying to
uh tamp down all of these different
conspiracy theories and steve bannon's
certainly not uh
not making any easier uh we will have
more coverage of this
and other vaccine related conspiracy
theories
on our instagram at david pakman show
and you can follow me on instagram as
well at david.pacman
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpacman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
joining us on the program today is bill
share
who many in the audience love to hate
and
some hate to love i think we would say
um contributor to the washington monthly
political magazine
real clear politics and also host of the
history podcast
when america worked bill always good to
have you
great to talk to you as well so let's
start maybe with
something that will shock the audience
if you had to say
what's your biggest criticism of biden
so far
where do you stand well i would say look
i've been very annoying about this from
the get-go
i think biden needs to find a way to get
the 60 on things or at least try
to get the 60 on things uh you can't do
everything through budget reconciliation
you're not going to abolish the
filibuster with mansion cinema's
opposition
even if you reform the filibuster that's
not eliminating the filibuster it
doesn't mean that
uh everything's going to glide right
through you know if that got changed
so on things like you know voting rights
immigration minimum wage uh
you need to find a path to 60 or it's
not going to happen
uh and so i think you need that
breakthrough you need that
there's so much mistrust you need a
breakthrough moment to create that
working relationship
i think the relief bill was the best
chance to get that
and i can't begrudge biden for
thinking hey i got 50 votes in hand i
can get 1.9 trillion
i can make a massive dent in child
poverty
i'm gonna act when i can act i mean
that's not an unreasonable calculation
to have made
but i do worry that if
it's a missed opportunity to get the 60
on something
is he going to be able to get the 60 on
anything right
well so uncovered relief i mean listen
it's like if you step back
there's a story to tell that's very uh
compelling right now which is
he promised 2000 and to us that sounded
like 2
000 more but then it became adding 1400
to the 6th
to the 6th and he said right away but it
took two months and he said 15
minimum wage and then that's gone and
then you kind of
you break it down and it's okay right
away
i mean how quickly can this actually be
done so so maybe
expectation should have been different 2
000 total versus 2 000 more
yeah i don't know i i was i was thinking
he meant 2 000 more as well
counting 600 from six months prior is a
little bit of a question mark to me
minimum wage listen the parliamentarian
thing
it it you know you could overrule the
parliamentarian but then you almost
certainly lose at least one democratic
senator
if you force it into the bill so it
really wasn't going to pass and then i'm
kind of like i guess this is okay i
don't know
well look just taking the bill in of
itself forget my own forget forget my
screamishes about what comes next
yep it's a very popular bill right the
criticism of 1400 versus 2
000 that's not resonating in the country
the the checks were the most popular
aspect of the bill and all the polling
that i saw
that's important which is 2 000 more
or 2000 total is huge in the political
space
but when you poll people they're happy
about the 1400 period
they're up to the 1400 i i think they
are going to be happy
at least the parents are going to be
happy about the expanded
child tax credit yeah when those monthly
checks uh come in
uh and uh to get a win off the bed is is
is no small thing you want to show
you're acting he was able to act within
50 days that is a good shot in the arm
for any an initial president so
i i don't think any in the short term
it's all good the question now is
can he find a way to get something
else that would show hey
i can find 10 republicans who can move
us on these other
fronts because because the the risk is i
mean look right in right now you
mentioned the minimum wage thing yeah
there's two things about the minimum
wage 15 million wages that are of note
one is that you do not have 50
democratic centers for 15
right they do not exist you lost eight
vote eight senators on that on the
democratic side on that vote so
it goes beyond the parliamentary
um the rules questions there right uh
so some people say well biden betrayed
his promise he didn't betray his promise
you never had 50 democrats who promised
that
in the first place undeniable so you
need to work on those eight
or you need to accept less than 15
and get the 60 some way somehow
but at the same time biden showed
he is very reluctant to bend those rules
and break those norms and
i think he is at least in the near term
stuck between these two positions
stuck between i'm going to get done what
we need to get done
and i'm not going to let the republicans
veto my agenda
but i'm not going to push hard to change
the rules right those two positions
don't mesh
something's got to give because if
you put a minimum wage bill on the floor
you put a voting rights bill on the
floor
you put an immigration bill on the floor
and they all get filibustered and you
don't move
one way or the other then you get i
think you get much
bigger frustration beer confusion yeah i
don't get what you're doing guy
pick a lane yeah yeah yeah and for
people who are watching and they thought
bill just pulled out a second microphone
that was actually
his cat's tail um so bloomberg reported
yesterday the next big focus is going to
be
tax reform everything that is being
reported as
being in the bill are things biden ran
on so there's there's no shock there in
terms of what
would be in the bill the white house
restating
taxes wouldn't go up for anyone earning
under four hundred thousand dollars a
year
that seems to be mostly true although
depending on what's
in changes for path pass through
business entities
that may or may not actually be the case
but we we have to wait and see
what i said earlier in looking at the
details of this
is that i think you're going to get
total republican opposition to doing
anything that could be
labeled a tax increase given the
pandemic situation
and probably even some democrats on
everything other than raising the
corporate tax rates so
while a lot of it is exactly what biden
promised
and what the uh many economists say
would be um a deficit negative revenue
positive however you want to do it i
think that
politically the next year would be very
tough for most of what's in that
a proposal well this is the tough thing
when when you
say republicans are beyond the pale
there's no way you're gonna get 10 on
anything it's a fool's game it's lucy in
the football
don't embarrass yourself by trying yup
get what you can get done
with 50. that only works if you have
50. right uh so taxes
and spending you can do through
reconciliation those are budgetary
matters
so the thing that's big up on a buyer's
agenda coming up is infrastructure
you can do infrastructure by and large
to reconciliation
and there's probably a tax component to
that
but if you don't have unanimity among
your 50 democrats
not only can you not get it done it is
much more politically embarrassing to
not get it done
because all the fault is on you you said
you were gonna do these things with your
party and you can't get your party in
line
that's very politically dangerous uh so
if you don't have that expectation that
you need 60 on these things if you if
if the assumption was uh in the populace
oh yeah you need 60 on these things we
need to have bipartisan support
oh republicans the one holding this up
i'm going to punish those guys
in november if the expedition is 50 and
then you don't get it done then you take
all the blame and we know that mansion
we know that angus king
we know that some other democrats are
squeamish about more
spending without offsets without revenue
whether that's tax increase or spending
cuts
and what those tax increases and
spending cuts should be
that's where things get very dicey to
talk a little bit about the republican
party
um one of the most frequent you know i
get
ten forms of these questions every week
is the republican party still the party
of trump
is the 2024 nomination trumps if he
wants it what happens in 2022 with
people that are really only known for
being trumpists like marjorie taylor
green lauren bober and madison cawthorne
etc
to me it seems that these things are all
sort of interrelated trumpet is cpac
speech
not announcing 24 but saying donate to
me
and i'll be the king maker and we're
going to get the rhinos out
is is 2022 and
maybe adjudicating these trumpian
members of congress in 2022
is that a signal about the future of the
party
well yeah i i would assume so i mean it
seems like trump
is is still in the game yeah we can we
can
speculate whether he went to 2024 or not
but he he's not taking a breather he's
not just playing golf he
he is getting involved in primary
battles encouraging primary battles
putting his thumb on the scale uh you
know we'll have to see
how many people get nominated or get
ousted in republican primaries
uh because of trump's involvement
uh and then we'll see in the general
election
if being trumpy helps or hurts
in a general election we we have had
examples in the past
where republicans went too far off the
deep end
and lost winnable seats uh
there's a great expectation that 2022
will be a good republican year i mean
right terms
go well for the president's party uh
there's a number of tenuous
house seats that are up uh and i mean
republicans have to do some defending on
the senate side
uh but uh and there's also the
registering question will republicans
draw lines for the house races that will
advantage them in 2022 that's that's all
a little unclear at this point
but there's a certain expectation that
this will be a good republican year
if trump blows it for them if there were
things that they could have won
and trump's involvement hurts them that
does not
that that might bring out the voices in
the republican party
saying hey this should not be trump's
party he has heard it he hurt us in
georgia
in 2020 and he's still hurting us now or
there may be folks that say
who cares who cares if we win or lose
this is trump's party
you know live or die and we're we're
going to fight the fight and fight the
liberals and the secular media and the
socialists
and who wins the elections is secondary
to us
uh we don't know you know how much trump
has
mutated the dna of the gop where they
become
immune to caring about electoral
considerations
right i mean you see polling like 64
percent of republicans would follow
trump to a new party
80 something percent want trump to
remain involved in politics in
some way it seems as though the
electorate is
far more positive on trump than the
elected officials are
privately from what the reports are but
it seems the elected officials are still
being careful
because they don't seem to know what the
power of trump will be in the next
election cycle or two
yeah they're afraid they're afraid for
their own seats and
most republicans who are in office now
can only lose their seats through a
primary not through a general
there's not a lot of crossover uh
split ticket purple state purple
district republicans at this point
uh now having said that and i have a
theory
that's not based on a ton of history
because there's only so many examples of
this
but i think you've got to lose the
presidency
three times in a row before party can
conclude
hey it's not you it's me you know
democrats
lost with carter lost with mondale lost
with dukakis
then you get bill clinton then you get a
guy running on welfare reform a guy who
will
execute a prisoner with with a 70 iq
uh a guy who will assist a soldier jesse
jackson to his face
and say and have the base voters say
well what are you gonna do
and you gotta you gotta attack the
middle we tried it the liberal way it
didn't work
you gotta really lose a lot right or
your base voters to say i'm really sick
and tired of losing
and your average trump die hard is not
sick of donald trump they have not lost
enough
to care now and maybe that my
rule of three doesn't work with trump
voters maybe they'll never care
because they're so uh wedded to him but
i think having the one loss
clearly is not sufficient to break that
bond yeah well
there's no doubt about that and
especially when you know that a lot of
the trump people
were not really involved in politics
anyway so a lot of those
sort of norms may not apply and many
republicans might rationalize
yeah we lost one but trump wasn't even
really like the rest of us anyway he was
sort of this other thing so so there may
be a lot of there on
both in the trumpian wing and the
non-trumpian wing there may be
rationalizations for why they won't care
well you know lindsey graham said it
pretty openly to axios that
you know trump has a good side and a
dark side but clearly he brings out
a certain group of voters that the
republicans need and so we gotta stick
with that but you know in his heart
lindsey graham's not a trump but not
trumper but you but he's sucky up to him
he thinks that's what the party
uh needs to do now to go back to my
other point about biden
and get into 60 i don't think this is a
unanimous
feeling amongst all republicans
especially senate republicans we know
there's a class
of senate republicans that does not care
for trump whether they are
the mitt romneys and lisa murkowskis and
the susan collins or the folks who are
saying sia
like rob portman and richard burr uh and
roy blunt
you they don't they don't want the party
to be a trumpian party now
we don't know how far they will go
to cause a rift we know that
it's not something that can happen
magically organically because they
stayed in lockstep against the rescue
plan against the pandemic relief bill
right
if you were to exploit those divisions
you need to work
at it and uh now some people might think
you're naive bill there's you can't work
hard enough there's no way to break
that bond and look that may be the case
i can't
mind read these republicans yeah but i
do think there
there is evidence of differentiation
between those senators
that i would like to see tried to see
could could you exploit that
call why didn't that rift make the case
to the romneys and the portman saying
look
it's not just good for me it's good for
you
it's good for your party you don't want
your party to be a trumpian party you
don't want your prayer to be
a nihilistic party show that we you can
work with us
and it'll be good for your party long
term uh
again i can't believe it's gonna work
but i would certainly try it
and i think it will make biden look good
in the trying
uh to occupy a space where he's putting
plans on the floor that are popular with
the public
and if they get blocked by republicans
republicans pay the price
yeah that's that's treasury i would like
to see more of yeah i i think that the
it would unquestionably make joe biden
look good and and that may be why there
will be desperation to avoid
the breaking of the ranks from from the
republican party but we will see which
uh
which forces is stronger in the end i
mean quite quite frankly that's what
it'll come down to
bill share contributor to the washington
monthly
to politico magazine to real clear
politics and also host of the
history podcast when america worked bill
it's always great to have you on
you too talk to you soon
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media
we depend on the support of our viewers
and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
slash david pakman show
fox news host tucker carlson continues
to tell us that he's not an anti-vaxxer
he's said on his show many times lately
i am not an anti-vaxxer
but yesterday on his program he did a
very anti-vaxxer thing which is under
the guise of i'm just asking
questions and some people are getting in
trouble for asking these questions he
set up a segment about
vaccines basically the same way that
anti-vaxxers
do and tucker carlson apparently hasn't
heard of google
or medical studies check this out so all
of this should prompt some pretty tough
questions for our public health experts
in this country
and one of those questions is how
effective is
this coronavirus vaccine how necessary
is it
to take the vaccine don't dismiss those
questions from
anti-vaxxers don't kick people off
social media for asking them
answer the questions so the questions
that tucker
thinks people are getting trouble
getting in trouble for asking
are questions that have been number one
discussed and debated and studied for a
year
and number two about which endless
peer-reviewed data
is available with a simple google search
for
his first question was how effective are
the vaccines we know how effective they
are
the moderna vaccine is 94 effective with
a 95
confidence interval after two doses of
preventing illness and it is virtually
100
effective at preventing severe covet the
pfizer vaccine
is 95 effective with a 95
confidence interval and is 89
effective at preventing serious covid
the johnson johnson vaccine is 72
percent effective but it was remember
tested later on the current variance and
probably
if you tested the moderna and pfizer
against the variants
you would see similar numbers those were
tested earlier when there were fewer
variants around and again
the jnj also 100 effective
at preventing sirius covid and then the
astrazeneca vaccine being rolled out in
some countries is 70
effective and 100 effective at
preventing serious
covid we know how effective they are we
also know how safe they are
the rate of anaphylactic reactions
serious allergic reactions
is about 0.025 percent
with everyone that experienced an
anaphylactic reaction recovering
and 98 of vaccine recipients have no
allergic reaction at all remember that
fever is not an allergic reaction
uh that that is um uh the the vaccine
working
we're talking about actual allergies
here so we have these answers
we know the data no one's getting in
trouble for asking how effective is the
vaccine that's a great question because
the answer is such a positive one
uh and the the and a knowable answer
now how important is it to take the
vaccine that's also a fine question to
ask
the problem is that too many people
aren't smart enough to understand the
answer
and to realize what herd immunity is and
that your personal risk level
is not the only factor in determining
whether you should or shouldn't
get vaccinated now i don't think tucker
is an anti-vaxxer and in fact
my guess is that if he hasn't been
vaccinated already
he and his family all are going to get
the vaccine as soon as they can
i think this is the show that tucker is
putting on
because it plays well with his audience
i wouldn't
again he might already even be
vaccinated tucker is asking questions
that others get in trouble for asking
but
we actually have the answers and no one
is getting in trouble for asking those
questions people are getting
in trouble so called when they spread
nonsense like
the vaccine isn't a vaccine but a dna
modifier
or the vaccine is microchipped or
they're planning to roll out forced
vaccinations or whatever the case may be
the questions tucker uh are the
questions being asked by tucker
are basic scientific empirical questions
and that's that
but if his audience doesn't realize
there are such clear answers to those
questions
then this segment works and that's what
you have to understand remember that
when tucker was sued one of the defenses
that fox news lawyers put out there
was that his program is entertainment
and he regularly regularly uses
hyperbole
and other tools of of rhetoric and
entertainment not of news reporting to
make the show interesting
and viewers should understand that and
of course i understand that
i know many of you understand that chuck
tucker's show is not a news show but an
entertainment show
uh but a lot of the fox new news
audience doesn't and in fact
in fact fox news has made a killing
blurring the lines
between what is news and what is opinion
and one way
that they famously uh in media studies
this is a notorious thing that fox news
does they will
take their opinion hosts
opinions and then they will report on
them during the news hours and say
breaking tucker carlson asks why are
people getting in trouble
for asking how effective the vaccine is
that's how they
they deliberately and further blur the
lines between news and opinion and
i i know many of you know this but much
of the fox news audience doesn't
and uh that's why this works that's why
this does well and tucker
for all i know tucker is vaccinated and
he's asking these questions
merely as a ploy for ratings and
generating interest and
and in fact this wasn't the only crazy
thing that happened on fox news in the
last 24 hours i want to talk about some
of the others
we've been covering and sort of charting
the path of
right-wing media since the november
election
which included mostly in the immediate
all of the right-wing network networks
coming to the defense of donald trump
insisting or at least having guests on
to freely insist that
actually donald trump did win not joe
biden and then we saw kind of a fork
take place
some media outlets like oan and newsmax
went very hard for weeks and months
interviewing every single conspiracy
theorist with a
conspiracy theory about the election
this included mike lindell from mypillow
sydney powell the whole roster the whole
the
the whole central casting crew fox news
did some of that
early and lou dobbs and maria bartoromo
stuck with it longer
but fox news did step away a little more
quickly still
engaging with the same ideas but doing
it in in sort of a more coy way
to avoid as much legal legal trouble as
possible
then we've seen fox news
shift to biden criticisms that are
pretty much flaccid like
biden hasn't done a press conference yet
and a lot of dr
seuss coverage they're actually on week
three of dr
seuss coverage on fox news right now but
the last 24 hours
on fox news have been absolutely out of
this world
many of us don't regularly consume this
drivel so i'm going to give you kind of
a tour through
the last 24 hours so you can see how
they're framing the current
administration
which it's quite a popular
administration by by historical
standards joe biden with the highest
initial approval rating
of any president in nearly 30 years high
approval on covet handling the coveted
relief bill is popular even with
republican voters
even though not a single republican
house or senate member
voted for it so i already showed you the
tucker carlson kind of playing coy with
some anti-vaxxer talking points
just a reminder of that clip so all of
this should prompt some pretty tough
questions for our public health
experts in this country and one of those
questions is how
effective is this coronavirus vaccine
how necessary is it to take the vaccine
don't dismiss those questions from
anti-vaxxers
don't kick people off social media for
asking them answer the questions
and then here's other stuff from the
last 24 hours maria bartiromo who now
has
a new primetime show on fox news she's
been brought over from fox business to
fox news
she had donald trump jr on her show last
night
and he casually mentions joe biden's
history
of sniffing children in the context of
the andrew cuomo scandal if you're
watching you'll see
maria bartoromo's uh notable
facial reaction to this joe biden
probably not the best person to talk
about these things given his history of
sniffing children
etc so don jr really angry
and still desperate for his dad to like
him
and here don jr talks about a predator
now it sounds like don jr is talking
about his own dad but he's not he's
talking about andrew cuomo
this guy was made a hero when he seems
like he's maybe the biggest predator in
american politics today
now again you can stop emailing me
saying i'm ignoring the andrew cuomo
story or i haven't criticized
andrew cuomo we've covered it
extensively we've covered the
allegations and as i said before
cuomo might have to resign what cuomo is
accused of is terrible i've not defended
cuomo once
but if cuomo is a big predator for a few
accusations against him
donald trump has more than 40 assault
allegations against him
varying from you know an unwanted kiss
all the way up to uh rape and don jr
as usual is a total hypocrite but
imagine being fox news
saying andrew cuomo is accused of sexual
uh harassment and assault
let's bring on the son of the guy
accused by more than 40 women
to say andrew cuomo is the biggest
predator out there
it's you know the facts don't matter of
course
then yesterday fox news covered a
propaganda event
at the u.s mexico border with
republicans
at which republican house minority
leader kevin mccarthy claimed without
evidence
that people from yemen and turkey are
and iran are coming over to the united
states by crossing the u.s mexico border
illegally
and we go to monument three and you talk
to those agents
it's not just people from mexico or
honduras or el salvador
they're now fighting people from yemen
iran turkey
people on the on the terrorist watch
list they are catching
and they're rushing it all at once yemen
iran
and turkey they're coming over the
border
multiple lawmakers saying after kevin
mccarthy claimed this
we haven't heard that at all and
multiple lawmakers saying we've never
been briefed about this
we if this is going on we should be
briefed but we have no reason to think
that this is going on and they're
actually seizing on this
this morning i wasn't able to pull the
clip for today's show
this morning fox now covering it as a
story
that people from yemen and these other
countries are coming over we'll probably
talk about that more tomorrow
and then donald trump's former economic
advisor
said that to get rich people to pay more
taxes you should lower their tax rate
take a listen to this fair share the way
you get
upper income people to pay more in taxes
is lower their tax rate
not only will they have investment
incentives they will
also have no tax avoidance now we've
already discussed why this is wrong and
i'm going to try to explain it again
they say often that lower taxes on the
rich
make the rich want to invest in their
business
that is completely backwards if the tax
rate
let me i'll set up a scenario for you a
20
tax rate and a 70 tax rate
if the tax rate is 20 uh
i am more likely to just take my money
and run
than if the tax rate is 70 why
because i'm happier paying a 20
tax rate on my profit than i am paying a
70
tax rate on my profit now think about it
the other way
uh investing in your own business is tax
deductible right
if i say i'm going to get all new
equipment for the david pakman show i'm
going to spend 20 grand on new equipment
i don't pay taxes on that 20 grand that
20 grand is tax deductible so
am i more incentivized to avoid
a 70 tax rate or a 20
tax rate the answer is obvious you will
go through more
effort to avoid paying
70 cents on the dollar in tax as you
would to avoid
paying 20 cents on the dollar in tax
we've talked about this many times
before
so the big takeaway here is
understanding
the alternate universe that what we call
primary fox news
viewers are living in people who
primarily get their news from fox news
even if it's opinion and not news
and i think it's important to understand
that i i talked a couple years ago i
went
uh to rural northern indiana where um
where my girlfriend has some family and
spending time there and seeing people
grow up
around their church and shooting ranges
and they're told every day in church
that abortion is the most important
issue it's like
of course they're voting for republicans
and i think that similarly
understanding the environment of someone
who mostly gets their news from
fox news and maybe the things that their
similarly
right-wing friends and family share on
facebook of course they end up believing
the things that they believe and i think
it's important for all of us to
understand
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
many many comments about the new david
pakman show
graphics and intro and outro music
uh let's listen to what the eggman had
to say
oh my god is that new original sea music
it sounds like miami vice almost you
remember your original original
nathan michael marcuzzi dot ca
right is that a friend of yours anyway i
miss the original
uh music that you had for the original
original
but every time you change it up i love
it um
shalom brother i'm drinking a cup of
water right now
all right shalom eggman stay hydrated
here's another comment about it
david love the new intro man i gotta say
it
the david patman show
okay and one more hey david
this is jeremy from the bay area big fan
of your show just wanted to provide some
feedback
on uh some new things i heard in the
show today
monday the 15th number one the sound the
new soundtrack is pretty cool
sounds like a kind of stranger things
vibe i feel like i'm in qzar exactly and
a lot of people saying that
but many people very angry and you know
what's funny every time we've made a
change
over the past however many years we've
had like
six or seven times where we change
graphics theme music
or the set every time
as with anything the people who dislike
it are most likely to contact us
and what sometimes gets me is when
someone says like offhandedly like
you should change it back or i'm not
going to watch or listen anymore it's
like do you really think
that we make these changes so
half-heartedly
that because of one email we're just
going to change it all back i get that
not everybody likes it
people are resistant to change people
who dislike things are more likely to
write to you
but um so far i think our changes
have over the long term improved the
show
so we are sticking with it i know not
everybody likes it i hope you will stick
with the show as well
if you stop listening to the show or
watching it because of the theme music
i don't know that you really like the
show that much to begin with because you
can just skip over it by skipping
forward
20 seconds it's not a big deal but glad
to hear that at least
some people are liking it we've got a
great bonus show for you today
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using 45 percent
less water but with a stream of water
that's way more powerful than what you
get with other shower heads to get 15
percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman